our next guest star football basketball
player in Los Angeles went on to start
USC as a tight end went to the Dolphins
as a fourth round pick in 2013 he caught
80 passes with 7 touchdowns was named to
the Pro Bowl all wait that's Jordan
camera not Cameron Jordan
I never mind let's bring out the 16
pensive hand Jordan we're almost there
the guy in the glasses next to you is
the one who who wrote that well I think
did your dad go to brown he did well I
went to Dartmouth so it's kind of here
we go he was just better yeah Wow
pretty you got a sheet on cam Jordan
there I got to get the sponsor in there
I thought it was sponsored myself here
are you wait no I don't know you tell me
are you showing up just for the sake of
showing up yeah I just love the show I
mean how many times have you been on ok
so I'm saying you have to push I thought
you had sigh I'm damn Jordan
DCAM joy okay were you ever confused
with Jordan Cameron when we got drafted
I got drafted in the first round he got
drafted in the realm fourth the Browns
called me why I was I was chilling with
my d-line coach Bill Johnson at a time
who's going to a Super Bowl this year
great job bill we were driving from the
airport and I got a call from the Browns
called down they're like hey we're about
to select you I was like I mean I'm good
actually I think I've already been
selected but if you want to send that
check I'll take that okay so you had
already been taken in the first round so
this was the next day right and you were
gonna get drafted by the Browns no doubt
and I sitting there just like I mean
I'll take two sign imposing bonuses but
I refuse to go to Cleveland
the fourth Pro Bowl this year you made
indeed yeah was it fun yeah he went to
the Pro Bowl it was it was an amazing
time I feel like you know everybody just
had higher expectations for us but what
do you want to do if I'm you're the
Commissioner for a day let's what do you
want to do with the Pro Bowl actually
make a statement what we'll get to that
number right oh okay oh you know we I
mean I think it's a phenomenal time in
terms of the fan and fans interaction
with the players it's a great time for
the the players with families I got to
take my kids to Disney World they loved
it my son is three hopefully some memory
retention is starting to set in I'm
probably probably not probably have to
wait another year right
my daughter is 2 she could care less
where we are she's just happy to be
around family and my newest addition is
7 months so she absolutely does not care
where she is but that being said you
know we have great pictures you know the
everybody's down from Mickey Mouse
everybody's down for a little Universal
Studios but you gotta still play a
football that a quote-unquote football
game it it probably better if it was at
40 degrees in and raining it was the
last two years yes it's been raining
okay I have an idea here how about we go
to the Pro Bowl in the NFL guarantees
your contracts so if you play in the Pro
Bowl we're gonna guarantee your country
the Pro Bowl every time before the the
gyro your contract the entire contract
yeah why would I go to the Pro Bowl and
play it's a I mean it's a huge honor to
go to the Pro Bowl but not to play
it's huge honor to play in the Pro Bowl
um for for me I mean it was is a
no-brainer for me it's my legacy but
you've made the Pro Bowl but but it's
not even football though cam that's the
only thing is is it feels like you could
get hurt trying not to get hurt and I'm
sure there's players that have been
but we talked about you know the ability
to actually play I said a lot of anger I
had to get out you know I was so
frustrated I was fresh out a week last
year I was like two weeks out I still
had somebody out of hit and now I'm like
way better am I good yeah it kept me
from going to some random bar looking
for smoke it ended up on ended up on a
ticker where I'm not supposed to be okay
if the commissioner walked in right now
give him another week oh but let's say
he's sat down yeah you got two questions
to ask Commissioner of the NFL what will
the answer yes okay must be theoretical
yes so he's gonna sit down with you and
he's just saying thank you yeah I'd want
to know what is helmet-to-helmet and
then I'd also just like to know you know
in terms of a defensive player what can
we do to not get those you know roughing
the passer calls and how can we clarify
that because I mean even you take out
this the Saints Rams game you can look
at Kansas City and the Patriots game
where Chris Jones got a roughing the
passer on what was the ordinary hit I
mean for me it's just clarity there's
got to be you know in the in this NFL
there's got to be a standard that is
clear you know white or black and not so
much of this gray area so accountability
what a statement from the commissioner
right after the loss to the Rams just
acknowledging the mistake helped in any
way for you guys I mean you do a lot
more good than it would be not answering
at all yeah or even you know now he
probably can't answer but a week before
Super Bowl you're not gonna release the
statement now no he's gonna say
something he's meeting with the media
today ah they're good they're gonna be
asking about that because I just thought
that just come out and say we made a
mistake you know we make mistakes but we
want to we want to make sure that we
correct mistakes we want this this was
not intentional these are humans they
made the mistake
we want to have a better system in there
to ensure that something like this never
never happens if I'm the commissioner
and I say that to you are you okay I'm
okay on my own I'm okay with the team
I'm okay with the guys that we have in
our locker room I'm okay with you know
our city you talk about 53 men who put
together a season 54 we have Englishmen
on our team well you talk about our city
and everybody who's ever back to us
seven days out eight days out I'm a lot
better than I was seven days ago wait
who's the Englishman who's the 54th guy
Lord Byron his name is Alec or I call
him Lord Byron
my lord it just sounded so official
challenge Jenkins he's the defensive end
but you know he's part of that he's the
54th she's not in the 53rd man roster
that works at all 5050 for Lord Byron
Malloy advise oh he's on the reserve
team I'm not sure how that works you
know he's got a he's able to be on
practice squad for two years but he
doesn't count against I'm not sure okay
I'm just gonna smile and say my lord do
you feel like a Super Bowl was stolen
from you uh again you asked me this a
couple days ago I finally just got all
my pettiness all my spitefulness' all my
gray area out let's bring it back but
I'm all about positive let's bring it I
can I can say that you know within our
locker room we have a great combination
of core guys with high enough positive
energy to keep us in the same mindset
we've got a great core where we know how
close we were and how close we want to
be and finish off next year so now I'm
just gonna talk about Super Bowl 54 cuz
this is no longer happening okay who are
you rooting for and it's no longer
happen in my mind I'm ruined first Super
Bowl 54 who are you rooting for anybody
so before no 53 that's the thing I
thought it was like 5150 root for the
Rams because they're the NFC um can you
actually root for Tom Brady do I have to
root I can if I have to watch yeah and
will you watch
I probably not I'm a little scorned
still um but we talked about the
privilege for it is to be able to go to
Super Bowl I understand the hard work
that it gets there so when I do
eventually watch it if I don't watch a
Sunday I'll always come back and watch
it with some weeks later like you know
last year I probably watched it while I
was in Jamaica that was like ah alright
let me get this might I let me hit this
beach and let me review who won the
Superbowl yeah good for them but yeah
when you talk about you know I can't
root for anybody I mean I can root for
personal individuals like Brandon cooks
phenom retainment you know I'm gonna
form a teammate of mine
you know I can root for you know Marcus
Peters a big bay area guy disconnections
there you know CJ Anderson for McHale
guy I can almost wish that Jared Goff
does well you know you go to the
Patriots and of course you know you you
see what the Belichick system is and you
always have respect for it but I don't
know if route is the right word do you
even have now you face the Patriots back
in 2017 yeah we did did you say anything
to did you even get touch Brady yeah I
got it I think I got it Brady press him
a couple times he's got such a fast
release his poison pocket is bar nine
you just talk about how elite he's been
over you know the last what years long
time long time I don't know so it's it's
I was I was like 10 or 11 you know
before I was even really registering
what a route tree was he was out there
throwing touchdowns
so I guess same goes for my quit back as
well you talk about just how elite he's
been I've got nothing but great respect
for he's Cameron Jordan the Saints
defensive end and he's been to four Pro
Bowls Jordan men have tan whoa yeah you
and your dad have 10 Pro Bowls Jordan
men have 10 yeah that's pretty good not
bad well not bad father-son combination
of actual athletes I mean there's
there's like yeah there's quarterback
families that you know I mean they can't
beat us in a race now
so my dad could probably beat their sons
and the races right now but it is what
it is it is what it is I'm sure the
Matthews families probably have oh yeah
yeah
computer Bruce Bruce had quite a few the
Long's possibly between housing Kyle and
Chris you know I'm sure you know they
can match up but other than that you
know I'm putting our money on the Jordan
men but that's that's a whole nother
conversation
yeah but Jordan brand brand I feel like
you know today Michael Jordan then you
bring up the basketball fan but whatever
we're talk about legacy here here
football legacy
I'm relooking for you I picked you guys
to win the Super Bowl this year so I
felt like I got cheated too
I appreciate that I appreciate that I
feel it how about this you get in your
full uniform and let's go over to the
commissioners press conference I simply
forgot my helmet but I'm sure I can fly
back to northern our flock I can get
like what if we can get your how about a
Cleveland Browns helmet Jordan Cameron
hey it's thank you for spending time I I
mentioned this to say Quan Barkley
you're taking steps to get into this
business and you're doing it now whether
you're you you want to it feels like
you're taking the steps to do this for a
living
I do enjoy everything that it comes to
be a football player
I enjoy the NFL but when you're retired
and I enjoy doing this I enjoy your show
I mean time I've been here I've been
here let's call it half a dozen two
times yes yeah absolutely but do you
want to do this you want to be in the
business when you're done I don't think
that big picture I think of what's in
front of me I think of the work that we
now have to relay the foundation you can
still think of you should think a big
picture yeah I worry that when I'm a
little older I feel like I just had you
know one of my best years yet and I feel
like next year will be poised they have
even better year so you say you know
life after football I have a Inklings of
what I want to do but I can't you know
go ahead and put full time no no I
there's nothing wrong with that but I I
think it feels it feels like you could
make that transition I appreciate that
it feels like you should make the
transition look
good sound good personality be able to
give may not look good part I mean no
looking better yeah yeah looking looking
but you'd look a whole lot better if you
were gonna be out there on Super Bowl
Sunday no doubt I know you guys let me
down hope you're happy you know like I
make predictions so I picked you and the
Chargers to meet miss Super Bowl the
Commissioner screwed us both no say you
you were double wrong yes you you wanna
guess the Belichick system whose bit
what they've been what five or six again
yeah that's not surprising you know no
it's not you say the running game but
you be like which of the like a trite
he's Cameron Jordan not Jordan Cameron
and he goes to Pro Bowls he plays for
the Saints thank you for stopping by
much reshape for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]